JP, how's Hawaii?
>> What?
I could hardly hear you over
the sounds of the jungle.
Let me go over to that tree.
>> Okay, J.P.
>> That's better.
So how are you and
the developer doing besides all
the craziness with launching 0.5?
>> Pretty good.
I submitted Shopping List Plus Plus
to the Abbie's like you suggested.
We're a bit of a long shot what with
Grocery Grabber having just released
their next version, but you never know.
>> That's awesome.
>> And let's see, besides that, well we
finished everything on the wire frames.
>> Woo hoo.
That's great to hear.
Why don't you take me through everything
you guys have done for old times sake?
>> Sure thing.
Shopping List Plus Plus is turning
into a fully fledged experience, and
it's all thanks to you, the developer.
Starting with version 0.1, you made a
very basic prototype that just read and
wrote some data.
In version 0.2, you flush this out
more by incorporating FirebaseUI so
that you could list out shopping
lists and shopping list items.
In version 0.3, you added user
accounts as well as a bunch of
functionality like letting others know
that you're in the store shopping and
marking that you've bought items.
Version 0.4 might have been
our most triumph moment
when you overhaul the data structure
to allow for shopping list sharing.
You also added some pretty
snazzy sorting features.
In version 0.5,
you added offline functionality so
that the app caches data even
when it's not on the screen.
Also implemented a bunch of read,
write and
validation rules to make sure that
our data is properly formed and
that only the correct
people have access to it.
>> Nice, so I gotta ask, what about
that big security flaw you talked about?
>> Well, for the short term,
I basically got another engineer to
separate our password and email flow.
But we'll be looking into
incorporating a simplistic server,
maybe the later version.
Hey, Gregory and Walter are here,
and they want to say hi.
>> Dujippi!
My friend.
>> Hey.
>> Hey guys, great to see all of you.
Actually, I might need to sign off.
I don't like the way that
parakeet is looking at me.
>> Okay, bye.
>> Bye.
>> Have fun.
Well, that was an informative blast
from the somewhat recent past.
Man, I can't believe that
just three months ago,
I was sitting at a meeting with
the Bay Area Shoppers Group.
>> You've come a long way, and
you've come a long way too.
You now know how to read
data into Firebase.
>> You also know how
to take that data and
display it in real
time in a Firebase app.
>> Let's not forget users.
You also know how to create
authentication methods for
email and
another provider such as Google.
>> And you've learned how to create
firebase data schemas to avoid things
like nesting data while also
denormalizing your data.
This really helps you grow and
scale your apps.
>> You've also learned how to filter and
sort your data.
>> Finally, we learned how to use
Firebase's security rules language to
make our apps status secure.
>> That's a lot.
>> That is a lot.
You know what?
I feel like you deserve
this API as much as I do.
>> Yeah but more than a cell phone
duct taped to a cheap trophy,
we hope you feel empowered to
create your own apps in Firebase.
>> Actually that reminds me,
I have another venture that I
wanted to talk to you about.
And I can actually send
over the spec right
after we all take a well deserved rest,
so yeah, let's go ahead and do that.
Speaking of which, Holder's taking
forever with that Instarito.
>> Yeah, where is he?
Where is he?